dans une certaine mesure de dire non
deux singes le malheur c'est que quand
on dit descente des sages on a
l'impression qu'on descend des
chimpanzés et pas du tout les chimpanzés
et nous savons cousin à jour mais en
maternelle qui était bretonne me disais
si toi tu descendu sa joie sur europe 1
a révélé nous a secret vous en avez
mangé du mam ou je me trouve à fouiller
en sibérie et puis un bon matin dans le
trou que j'avais commencé à creuser
je trouve de lait tout comme ce quelque
chose de bien les grands filaments je
suis étonnée je râle je dirais que ce
sont des collègues russes qui sont venus
tripatouiller le fond de ma recherche et
puis à force de tirer dessus comme rien
ne venait je me suis aperçu que j'étais
sur le dos
[Musique]
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce mardi 7 décembre
emmanuel macron est-il en pleine
campagne à quatre mois de la
présidentielle le chef de l'état sortant
pas encore officiellement candidat est
en tout cas en immersion dans la france
des terroirs à vierzon dans le cher il a
été interpellé notamment sur les petites
retraites et la vie chère vierzon
justement l'un des symboles du mouvement
des gilet jaune un électorat convoités
par les candidats alors question ce soir
pour qu'ils vont rouler les gilet jaune
en étant vos réactions sur le comté d g
d'herbe est français on en débat tout de
suite après avec d'anciennes figures du
mouvement
joseph haydn et vladimir poutine se sont
entretenus par visioconférence cet
après-midi deux heures de sommet entre
les présidents américain et russe pour
éviter une escalade en ukraine les etats
unis l'otan et kiev accuse moscou de
préparer une invasion sera en direct
avec un autre correspondant dans la
capitale russe où le kremlin dément ces
accusations et puis direction ensuite
washington joe biden a déclaré qu il
téléphonera demain ses homologues
européens brandissons des menaces de
sanctions économiques sur moscou
décryptage en plateau
au sommaire à 21h la lutte contre la
cinquième vannes du coronavirus en
france renforcement du protocole
sanitaire dans les écoles dès demain le
port du masque sera requis dans les
cours de récréation le gouvernement qui
étudient aussi la piste de la
vaccination pour les enfants de 5 à 11
ans emmanuel macron lui qui fait de la
vaccination des européens une question
d'appartenance au président français qui
va jusqu'à ironiser d'ailleurs sur
l'efficacité du vaccin rue spoutnik v
les vaccins devenu alors une bataille
géopolitique on en débat dans la
troisième partie d'émission
[Musique]
emmanuel macron serait-il en campagne
dans le cadre d'un déplacement de deux
jours il s'est rendu aujourd'hui dans le
cher au contact des français entre bar
tabac et boulangeries avec en première
étape ce matin bière dont on retrouve
notre reporter et midi goût gage bonsoir
emilie
parler par hasard d'un début de campagne
pour emmanuel macron
eh bien c'est fini on a peut-être un
président pas encore candidat mais il
semble bien en campagne vous l'avez dit
il est donc arrivé à vierzon pour une
immersion auprès des français le
président veut clairement renouer avec
la france rurale évoqué avec les
français leurs tracas du quotidien
il a été interpellé à part des
commerçants mais aussi des habitants de
la ville de vierzon ils leur ont confié
lui ont confié leurs inquiétudes
notamment en raison de la situation
sanitaire c'est le cas d'un patron de
discothèque à d'ailleurs reproché au
chef de l'état la fermeture des
établissements demi pour quatre semaines
et cela dès vendredi est venue l'heure
de déjeuner ça s'est passé dans un
relais routier de bourges le président a
ensuite rencontré des auxiliaires de vie
sociale il a également visité un atelier
textile de réinsertion doute beaucoup
donc de proximité avec les français
aujourd'hui enfin on en arrive à ce soir
bien sûr où emmanuel macron assiste au
dernier conseil municipal de l'année
dans une ville du sud du berry il s'agit
de châteaumeillant un dîner est prévu
avec les élus de cette commune qui a à
peine plus de deux mille habitants bref
une journée avec un programme très
chargé beaucoup de rencontres beaucoup
de mains serrées mais pourtant le
président o dément être en campagne oui
on va essayer de le croire et mini alors
est ce qu'on peut dire qu emmanuel
macron cherche en tout cas à se
distancer des autres candidats
c'est bien ce que l'on peut penser
d'autant plus après la publication de ce
sondage et lab pour bfmtv l'express un
sondage qui vient de tomber il révèle
que valérie pécresse serait gagnante
face à emmanuel macron au second tour la
candidate désignée samedi au congrès les
républicains obtiendrait 52% des
intentions de vote contre 48% pour le
président sortant l'annoncent d'une
forte percée de valérie pécresse
pourrait concrétiser le fait qu'elle
soit le pire cauchemar des manuels
macron comme l'avait confié un des
soutiens de la candidate autres
candidats qui pourraient peut-être aussi
causer du tort à emmanuel macron il
s'agit bien sûr d'eric zemmour justement
demain le président se rend dans
l'allier à vichy ce sera une première
pour un chef de l'état depuis
1978 en fait rare qu'un président s'y
rendent le dernier c'était valéry
giscard d'estaing c'était donc il y à 40
ans une ville au passé et historiquement
loup le maréchal pétain il y avait
installé l'état français à l'été 1940
une ville qui n'a pas été choisie par
hasard par emmanuel macron il s'agit
peut-être pourra le président d'envoyer
un message à eric zemmour qui
souvenez-vous été accusé de vouloir
réhabiliter pétant c'était dans un de
ses livres merci beaucoup emilie et
boogat h en direct de l'elysée en tout
cas à côté parce qu'on n'a toujours pas
dans un crédit tation évidemment lé 10
et de toute manière emmanuel macron n'y
était pas aujourd'hui alors on va plus
loin avec alexis poulain sur l'actualité
politique de la journée avec notre
éditorialiste donc
alexis c'est la rubrique édito
bonsoir alexis emmanuel macron de retour
des émirats et qui repart immédiatement
en campagne à la campagne aujourd'hui à
vierzon demain dans dans l'allier à la
rencontre peut-être deux de ses futurs
électeurs en tout cas peut-être
l'espère-t-il en secret même s'il n'en
sans défense oui alors est-ce clairement
de retour des émirats là c'est plutôt
rendez vous en terre inconnue c est mené
le maquereau dans cette france
périphérique qui ne connaît pas il a été
critiqué pour être ce président des
riches le président hors sol c'est une
france qu'il a du mal à rencontrer à
connaître et de par laquelle il n'est
pas forcément aimer et on voit bien que
depuis septembre depuis ces annonces à
marseille emmanuel macron essaie de
colmater toutes les brèches en fait de
sa candidature toutes les fautes les
défauts qui pourraient avoir pour être
le candidat parfait et donc essayé bas
de rencontrer les gens de faire des
tours de passe-passe de distribuer de
l'argent notre argent et puis de faire
campagne en rencontrant tous les gens
qui pourrait lui dire qu'il a oublié
tous ces gens là pendant son quinquennat
enfin les gilet jaune qui étaient
nombreux à vierzon c'est une des
premières villes de ce mouvement
n'oublierons pas le nombre des
manifestants gilet jaune qui ont été
épargnées la violence d'état qui s'est
abattue sur eux je crois que ça sert à
rien d'essayer de rabibocher des gens
qui ont été traités de cette façon là
par emmanuel macron alors il n'y a pas
que emmanuel lacroix qui cherche à
parler à la france des périphs ellien
eric zemmour aussi rejoints par les
figures des gilet jaune comme jacqueline
moreau benjamin cauchy ça sera
d'ailleurs notre invité dans quelques
instants avec jérôme rodriguez et bien
sûr là la france insoumise avec toujours
évidemment comme stratégie le
recrutement des abstentionnistes oui on
veut bien qu'on est en campagne
électorale puisque c'est s'est oublié un
permanent de la politique sont en train
d'être un peu draguer par tout le monde
alors eric zemmour si vous voulez
adhérer à reconquête il ya même un
anglais un français dans la précarité ou
dans en difficulté vous pouvez donc
payer uniquement 10 euros un plus tôt
que 50 euros également si vous êtes
étudiant donc je suis allé voir le site
incroyable incroyable mais ça reste
quand même dix euros quand vous êtes
dans la difficulté c'est quand même une
somme
et puis évidemment l'idée c'est de dire
avec jacquet de muro avec benjamin
cauchy l'ale politique d gilet jaune
puisqu'il s'était déjà présenté faisait
déjà de la politique a rejoint eric
zemmour il faut voir que
sociologiquement les gilet jaune sont
quand même une foule qui rejette le jeu
partisan parce que il ya quand même
quelque chose de l'ordre du système chez
eric zemmour on trouve les mêmes
financiers que chez emmanuel macron par
exemple ça n'a échappé à personne donc
il y a des limites à tout ça et puis
chez jean luc mélenchon lui c'est l'idée
de d'essayer de capter les voix des
abstentionnistes de dire que si jamais
tous les gens qui ne votent pas
d'habitude aller voter on parle de
millions de voix ça changerait
totalement la donne d'une élection et
c'est vrai qu'en ce moment on voit que
tout est possible sondage après sondage
dans finalement maintenant les candidats
sont connus mais aimerait macron n'est
pas encore déclaré candidat et on voit
bien qu'il est certes en campagne mais
que chacun est en train de préparer sa
campagne et à gauche injustement l ex il
vous en avait déjà un petit peu parlé de
cette gauche toujours quand même le flou
des voies plus qu'est parce si on en
croit effectivement les sondages oui le
dernier sondage est là bas alors à
prendre avec des pincettes parce que du
matin au soir valérie pécresse prend 4
millions de voix elle passe de
la technique des sondages c'est le point
de ses excès en ligne il ya toujours une
marge d'erreur on peut les critiquer
mais il donne quand même globalement une
idée de température s et la température
aujourd'hui en france on voit bien que
le camp de droite la droite
traditionnelle est en train de reprendre
de la vigueur à suite au congrès et
valérie pécresse devance eric zemmour ce
n'était pas forcément gagné il ya
quelques mois et puis maintenant eric
zemmour est au coude à coude avec marine
le pen emmanuel macron est en train de
descendre une grignotera pas plus
finalement que ces 23 25% donc sur un
second tour tout est possible si un
candidat de la droite des républicains
si valérie pécresse arrive à passer et
qu'elle arrive à fédérer ou partie des
électeurs d'eric zemmour mais 4 millions
de voix ça voudrait dire qu'ils auraient
beaucoup de voix d'électeurs de gauche
aujourd'hui on est loin de ce
rassemblement là autour de valérie
pécresse donc des sondages encore à
prendre avec des pincettes mais qui
montre quand même un débat fortement à
droite pour cette présidentielle de 2022
merci alexis poule a alors question quel
candidat un concept électorat populaire
cette catégorie de france est scrutée à
la loupe et convoités par les candidats
ceux notamment on vient d'en parler qui
ont défilé tous les week-ends pendant
plus de quinze semaines d'affilée d'où
notre débat ce soir pour qu'ils vont
rouler les gilet jaune on attend
toujours vos réactions sur le conte
télégramme d'ayrté france passe au face
à face
avec nous pourrons en parler en direct
jérôme rodriguez ex figure d gilet jaune
bonsoir jérôme rodriguez merci d'être
avec nous à vos côtés distance à
benjamin cauchy conseiller en
communication ancien gilet jaune
également benjamin cauchy qui ai décidé
de soutenir eric zemmour bonsoir à tous
les deux après avoir été épargnée en
léger les jaunes vont être certainement
très courtisé ce que vous pensez que cet
électorat pèsent lourds et peut faire la
différence jérôme rodriguez
l'électorat gilet jaune s'il pèse lourd
oui ça va être un électorat très
convoité comment on l'expliqué le jeu je
sais pas s'il serait très lourd je la
seule chose que je sais c'est
qu'aujourd'hui à beaucoup de gens qui se
permettent de parler au nom des gilet
jaune et le premier d'entre eux c'est
monsieur benjamin cauchy messieurs
majeur macuxi pour l'anecdote c'est une
personne que j'ai eu au téléphone c'est
le tout premier gilet jaune que j'ai eu
au téléphone et il me parlait déjà de
politique parce qu'il était derrière
monsieur dupont-aignan et puis quelque
part elle a gravi les échelons et
aujourd'hui il arrive au top il arrive
au summum il arrive chez chez monsieur
zemmour sauf que ce qui m'attriste chez
benjamin cauchy pour qui j'ai quand même
quand même de la sympathie parce qu'on a
on a su les battre et discuter ce qui
est ce qui me chagrine c'est qu'en tant
qu'ancien gilet jaune
il se permet de parler au nom des jets
légende en disant que les filets jaunes
sont pour zemmour alors que lui même
sait très bien que les gilets jaunes ne
marche pour personne car ils savent très
bien et on l'a ressenti ne sait ce que
dans l'édito qu'a pu fournir alexis que
les gilet jaune aujourd'hui nous
sanctionne pour personne ne vont
derrière personne pas plus ses mots pas
puisque mélenchon encore moins macron ni
même ni même tout ce qu'on peut nous
proposer dans l'immédiat parce qu'on a
bien compris que ce soit l'un ou l'autre
c'est blanc bonnet et bonnet blanc et
encore moins avec des idées racistes
quand on voit notre est la population et
gilet jaune qui est quand même un 10
pages de l'ensemble de la population
française et qui est aussi multicolores
et je suis désolé mais au sein du
cortège de gilet jaune il ya des mois
mais dd boubacar et ce serait
regrettable qu'ils soient amenés à
changer de prénom voilà aujourd'hui si
on reprend le programme de zemmour qu'en
est il de son programme économique qui
est quand même quelque chose qui
intéresse principalement les gilet jaune
mise à part tous les immigrés dehors
pour retrouver du boulot il n'y a pas
quelque chose de très intéressant à
proposer d'autres voilà donc les gens
aujourd'hui
stéphanie
ceux qui se permettent de parler au nom
des gilet jaune ne sont déjà plus gilet
jaune benjamin conseiller la réponse
oui bonsoir et merci de votre invitation
parce que j'ai surtout envie de dire
effectivement au gilet jaune qui nous
écoute que effectivement chacun chaque
gilet jaune à son courage à son à sa
conviction politique à un certain rejet
ou un certain dégoût de la classe
politique nous a conduits jusqu'à et
bien l'abandon de l'état auprès des
citoyens qui ont envie de s'en sortir et
moi j'ai surtout envie de parler aux aux
citoyens qui se sont levés le 17
novembre 2018 on a obtenu entre 17
novembre 2010 8 et le 11 décembre 2010 8
11 milliards d'euros date à laquelle à
quelques-uns nous avons pu et grâce à
tous ces centaines de milliers de
personnes dans la rue pouvoir obtenir 11
milliards d'euros une prime d'activité
et le gel de la taxe carbone sur le
carburant entre le 11 décembre 2018 est
aujourd'hui jérôme rodriguez que je
respecte également pour qu'ils nous
n'avons pas les mêmes comme dirais-je
les mêmes modes d'action en tout cas
nous voulons aussi faire changer les
choses on a pas on n'a pas choisi le
conte dirais-je la même direction les
mêmes modes d'action mais je pense qu'on
avait la volonté tous les deux farouches
parce que nous y eut donc notre vie et
notre temps nous voulons faire changer
les choses je réponds à jérôme sur le
pouvoir d'achat c'est vrai que c'est le
sujet prioritaire j'ai pas envie de
parler d'immigration avec toi je pense
parler de ça j'en ai parlé de ce qui
touche effectivement les français du 17
novembre eric zemmour il veut baisser la
csg sur les bas salaires pour créer un
treizième mois eric zemmour il veut
oblige les tous les employeurs de france
à verser jusqu'à 300 euros par an pour
financer le carburant parce que les gens
qui sont sortis dans la rue le 17
novembre 2008 jérôme c'était bien
comprend une taxe carbone c'était pas
pour avoir un plan climat c'était pas
pour soutenir greta thunder dans la rue
les gilet jaune et gilet jaune il aura
fallu que les gens comprennent que les
gilet jaune ne peuvent pas aujourd'hui
marché derrière un homme quel qu'il soit
parce que on a la quasi certitude
aujourd'hui que c'est pas un danger en
dedans s'élèvent souvent souvenirs je
vais te virer un homme ce n'est pas un
homme est un programme qui aujourd'hui
va sortir l'ensemble des de la merde
depuis des français excusez moi
l'expression d'accord c'est pas
constater aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est
on l'a constaté quoi qu'il advienne le
fait de parler pour les jeunes je te
rejoins dans l'idée que les gilets je
suis dans chaque lundi les jeunes ne
parlent pas pour les suisses étaient
entendus a ajouté je t'ai entendu dans
les grandes gueules dire que les gilet
jaune sont sont pour zemmour on ne peut
pas se permettre de dire ça longtemps
plaie je voulais faire c'était une
réalité on est on est pour les seniors
pourrait se dessiner c'est débattre mais
je voudrais quand même justement vous
parler de lui depuis quelques minutes
alors on va l'écouter ce c'est eric
zemmour justement qui est fait allusion
au gilet jaune ce matin chez nos
confrères de bfm écoutez
je comprends les îles et jaune j'aime ou
mamie jacqueline moreau qui est avec moi
qui a lancé le mouvement donc je les
comprends j'ai regardé ça vous fait
bondir benjamin cauchy jacky moreau
jolie léger des gens je les comprends
nous dit eric zemmour est ce que vous
vous serez bien compris l'amérique mon
une chose de plus a dénoncé un phénomène
de récupération comme il a été fait de
tous les côtés pour essayer d'attraper
les gilet jaune on est exactement sur ce
que l'on dénonce en tant que gilet jaune
si benjamin est un gilet jaune il se
doit de dénoncer ça cette espèce de
phénomène de récupération à coups de
promesses qu'on a depuis à mon niveau
quarante ans et qui n'avancera pas plus
aujourd'hui
excusez moi du peu mais en terme
d'économie vous avez zemmour ne prend
pas pneus propose pas plus que le medef
voilà un moment donné oué oué le
programme et quels que soient les
candidats ils veulent tous ept gilet
jaune aujourd'hui c'est une couleur à la
mode alors sur la sur l'action
aujourd'hui matin l'un est parti sur une
autre niveau nous sur l'action d'un
concert on a continué à être dans la rue
ok ça diffère aussi tous les deux
finalement noir dans le froid de ce que
vous souhaitez pour la france a
aujourd'hui ce qu'on souhaite déjà c'est
que peut-être que la parole de gilet
jaune puisse être écoutés entendus
d'accord et elle ne l'est pas d'accord
parce qu'il ya des discours aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont tenus quelle que soit le
bord et je ne fais aucune différence
parce que cette étiquette qu'on puisse
me donner ou pas je ne fais pas de
différence aujourd'hui on a la certitude
que de toute façon quelques quelle que
soit la personne qui rend au pouvoir le
rpt a les menottes au poignet ne faudra
pas plus on est dans une société néo
libérale capitaliste qui aujourd'hui
même les présidents attendez vous avez
dit vous avez des mecs qui aujourd'hui
ça ne l'est peut-être ne savent même
plus quoi faire de leur argent ils vont
se balader chatouiller les étoiles
pendant qu'il ya des gens qui crèvent de
soif après qu'un président aujourd'hui
qu'ils soient et mourront mâcon pécresse
a du pouvoir face à ces gens là bas
j'avais très bien compris que ce sont
des marionnettes et qui servent à rien
que je sois zemmour ou un autre n'a
jamais à quoi vous vous avez choisi eric
zemmour et en quoi justement il peut
vous
apporter les solutions dont parle à
jérôme rodriguez
j'ai discuté franchement avec eric
zemmour avant de m'engager avec lui je
lui ai bien dit que moi je n'étais qu'un
gilet jaune n'était qu'une personne qui
étaient sortis dans la rue de 17
novembre et qu'il y en avait des
millions d'autres qui avaient chacun
leur personnalité et chacun leurs
raisons de s'être engagé et qui avait
sans doute des aspirations différentes
donc moi j'ai dit à eric zemmour surtout
au delà de chasubles gilet jaune il
fallait parler aux gens qu'ils étaient
victimes du grand des classements aux
gens qui étaient sortis dans la rue le
17 novembre 2018 donc si ça peut faire
plaisir à jérôme jeu par dracula gilet
jaune je parlerai des français du 17
novembre 2018 ce qui ne sort merdé pas
avec la convention sur le climat qui
s'endettaient pas avec la tâte homberg
qui s'en remettaient pas les concessi
est il semblait qui s'en était pas avec
les traoré parce que leur question
c'était de savoir comment il allait
pouvoir vivre dignement de leur travail
comment il allait faire face à la
concurrence déloyale des travailleurs
détachés comment faisait faire pour
éviter le dumping social que
représentent nos amis nos amis par
exemple espagnols qui vont produire de
la tomate beaucoup moins cher le
producteur français s'est également les
artisans qui sont en train de crever les
artisans transporteurs qui sont en train
de crever de la concurrence de la
pologne donc nous ce qu'on veut c'est
pour ça que je trouve qu'ils récusent et
me répond aussi à cette attente des
citoyens du 17 novembre 2018 c'est de
refaire en sorte que ben la france
s'occupe des français
réindustrialiser le pays baisse la csg
sur les bas salaires imposées aux
employeurs à la fois de la participation
s'ils veulent verser des dividendes sa
cellule la position jérôme qui blasés
ben 10
rome s'est fini juste là pour 20
secondes par sp
d'ailleurs quand la politicienne a pris
dans la vente de l'éviction d'eric
zemmour dans la proposition d'eric
zemmour si les employeurs veulent verser
des dividendes à leurs actionnaires ils
auront l'obligation de verser de la
participation alors salariés ou c'est
déjà un gros coup de peinture
on a aussi donné la parole aux
téléspectateurs et on va regarder un
premier message télégramme dycker max
qui nous dit à la question de savoir
pour qui vont rouler les gilet jaune la
question volontairement un petit peu
provocante et qui met tout le monde dans
le même panier et pour vous faire réagir
messieurs et bien il vaut trop pour ce
qu'ils veulent mais beaucoup d'entre eux
ne voteront pas du tout jérôme rodriguez
est ce que justement il ya ce risque
d'abstention massif en tout cas on vous
vous ferez ces abstentionnistes
je réserve je réserve le monde droit de
voter ou pas parce que je vais vous dire
honnêtement à ton personnel si j'ai un
maquereau zemmour
au deuxième tour je vais voter quoi pour
un mec qui a des idées racistes et
pessimiste et où un mec qui m'a crevé un
deuil non moi je vais m'asseoir canapé à
tanger swan finir
canapé et je mange du pop corn
aujourd'hui il est clair que le
président de la france c'est
l'abstention d'accord que beaucoup de
gilet jaune ont travaillé derrière le
mouvement derrière la rue quand on
marche pour pouvoir s'intéresser ne
serait ce qu'à la reconnaissance totale
du vote blanc il serait peut-être gros
temps de s'y intéresser qui donnerait
peut-être moins de légitimité à un
parvenu comme macron qui se paie ton roi
du monde parce qu'il a hérité de 18 %
des votants et qu'il est devenu
président grâce à ça donc un moment
donné on n'a peut-être pas de
propositions concrètes
on a des propositions aujourd'hui qui
permettrait de contrer une personne qui
se prendrait pour le roi de france et
qui infligerait aujourd'hui des mesures
liberticides ou qui s'amuseraient à
crever des yeux à des manifestants qui
aujourd'hui ne réclamait que le pain la
dignité et l'existence voilà plus
simplement et la gorge dans ton ça
jérôme rodez la gauche devrait
logiquement répondre
le problème de la gauche si vous voulez
oui parce que fondamentalement je pense
en tous les cas et ça ça reste
personnelle que le mouvement des gilets
jaunes sur ce qu'ils réclament on est
sur des valeurs de gauche attention ça
veut pas dire que les jeunes sont de
gauche je finis juste mon propos
aujourd'hui toute la grande piste
ma grande tristesse sur la gauche
aujourd'hui et je rappelle que je suis
de gauche à titre personnel parce que
j'en ramasse plein la gueule moi je suis
un islamo gauchiste je suis peut-être
même un cristiano gauchistes tant qu'à
faire sauf que aujourd'hui ce qui me
fait de la peine chez la gauche c'est ce
manque d'union d'accord et le problème
c'est que dès que je commence à parler
sur la gauche c'est que je vais en
prendre plein la gueule - que peut-être
que quand j'en mets dans plein la
tronche aux autres sauf qu'aujourd'hui
la gauche ça part dans tous les sens
c'est inaudible c'est chacun son
assiette et que le meilleur mange c'est
incroyable je suis mais dépité désolé et
quand j'ai mais une critique parce
qu'aujourd'hui je suis triste de voir
l'état de la gauche par rapport à celles
que j'ai pu connaître quoique quasiment
inexistant ce face à une force de droite
qui est phénoménal je me dis il ya
quelque chose qui va pas aujourd'hui ça
fait 21 une semaine que monsieur
philippe au mas dans la rue je ne vois
pas la bouche réagir qui est quand même
son boulot premiers mois je dois
m'occuper la justice sociale fiscale
d'une d'une démocratie directe et
participative
on essaie d'élever nos voix face à du
travail pour proposer ça aux français et
proposer une autre façon de vivre aussi
mais aujourd'hui
on ne peut plus on ne peut plus on ne
peut plus même plus compter sur sur
l'ensemble du panel de politique c'est
c'est désolant c'est désolant personne
ne répond aujourd'hui aux attentes des
français d'ordre général pas que au
gilet jaune parce que j'ai quand même la
particularité d'avoir une tronche
visible et quand je suis dans la rue
j'ai affaire à tout le monde et il ya un
mécontentement et je vous garantis que
ceux qui vont arriver je le répète sur
le marché de la précarité aujourd'hui il
faut pas attendre de se faire crever les
yeux ou de se faire péter les dents pour
mende et montent beaucoup de pleurs plus
fort que les gilet jaune et je vous
garantis que les gilets jaunes vont
passer pour des agneaux à côté moi je
suis pas là pour [ __ ] la merde suis
pas là pour [ __ ] le feu en france où
là pour qu'on s'assoit autour d'une
table on fassent converger l'ensemble
des idées de l'ensemble du panel
politique des français parce que la
liberté de parole c'est celle ci je
passe mes week-ends à que les libertés
dans la rue c'est pas pour empêcher
quelqu'un de parler de réfléchir ou
d'agir mais pour discuter avec et
essayer d'améliorer le quotidien de tous
benjamin cauchy vous les anciens gille
et joli ou ton jour j'ai des jeunes
d'ailleurs que vous rencontrez qu'est ce
qu'ils vous disent ce qu'ils partagent
cette même colère qu'elle vient
d'exprimer jérôme weill est oui et plus
largement de la dea gilet jaune et là je
pense qu avec jérôme on peut partager le
même constat la première c'est que la
gauche ne répond pas au rendez vous de
l'appel populaire qu'a représenté le
mouvement le citoyen du 17 novembre 2018
il est et la deuxième chose c'est que
finalement les gilet jaune sont que
l'arbre qui cache la forêt des
abstentionnistes effectivement si on
doit parler à au français jérôme toi
comme moi c'est quand même de les
appeler à se bouger le cul si je puis me
permettre l'expression et la regarder et
leur demander quand même d'aller mettre
un bulletin de vote d'aller mettre un
bulletin de messi faut leur dire il leva
que et légers remonte se passer par le
vote
blanc si le vol moi aussi je suis pour
la reconnaissance du duduk du vote blanc
moi aussi je souhaite plus de référendum
et ça je les demande eric zemmour j'ai
également demandé zemmour qui failli
construire des logements parce qu'être
fier de son pays si on n'est pas capable
de mettre des patriotes sous un toit
pour protéger leurs familles c'est
inadmissible donc moi aussi jérôme tu
vois j'ai décidé de m'engager de façon
plus démocratique politicienne comme tu
dis mais j'ai gardé j'ai gardé les
raisons pour laquelle je suis sorti dans
la rue du 17 novembre mais même si j'ai
même si j'ai un pastiche politique j'ai
gardé j'ai gardé les mêmes faisait ce
jour s engager sur l'or là je respecte
cela et je ne te juge pas par rapport à
ceux là je te demande aujourd'hui de ne
plus parler au nom des gilet jaune cg
les gens de son lit zemmouri ce temps
sont ils ne sont pas pour le zemmouri ce
temps-là mélenchon ni le lepéniste ans
ou le maquereau distance est une
certitude absolue mais aujourd'hui les
gigues enseigne l'ancien doyen du 17
novembre l'ensemble détruit l'ensemble
de même même pas parce qu'aujourd'hui
j'appelle ça un ensemble de citoyens en
colère tu as yeux du 10 juillet 2021 qui
nous ont rejoint aussi d'accord qui
aujourd'hui manifestent depuis
vingt-et-un une semaine tu vois il n'y a
pas que des gilet jaune il ya
aujourd'hui une france en colère qui à
qui on ne répond pas et à qui on ne
répond que par la répression et ça nous
gérons machine permet de tout
interrompre sur ce sujet là si on nous
donne quelques secondes tu vois tu es en
train de parler du sujet du pass annie
terre et de la vaccination qui est un
vrai sujet qu'un sujet pas du moins pas
du tout juste de ça les gênait pas du
tout en parler avant des mesures
liberticides qui ont mis tous les
français dans la merde je ne parle là je
dis qu'il ya des français en colère il
ya des français en colère qui ont
rejoint
le mouvement de l'ensemble des français
en colère un 12 juillet je suis désolé
il ya le clip est père et les passe à la
télé - unis j'ai pris dix mille abonnés
sur ma page 10 me mécontents de plus et
je te garantis que c'est pas de gilet
jaune 90 milles sur l'été et bien c'est
ça il faut qu'il faut parler à tous les
français qu'il faut laisser tomber cette
histoire et gilet jaune jérôme gerome je
pense que si on avait quelque chose dans
les filets jaunes je vais les garder sur
les jeunes je suis
je veux juste
en effet un danger sérieux je ne suis
pas propriétaire des jets des jeunes je
suis regardé français je suis garé
landais pour l'histoire je suis garant
de l'histoire des gilets jaunes et de ce
que sont les gilet jaune les fréquente
depuis dix ans voulait pas manifestants
pour est en berne ils voulaient ma pas
manifestés pour traoré il voulait pas
monsieur mais le 5 pouces et merci à
tous les deux merci messieurs jérôme
rodriguez benjamin construit en tout cas
d'avoir accepté ce débat ce soir en
direct sur rt france et on vient d'en
parler hein donc merci c'est gilet jaune
qui attendent des actions concrètes
évidemment pour améliorer leur quotidien
et augmenter leur pouvoir d'achat
promesse faite d'ailleurs récemment par
le gouvernement face à la hausse des
prix d'électricité
une enveloppe à 4 milliards d'euros en
2022 mais cette promesse pour écouter le
cher que prévu estelle farges
initialement évaluée à 10% la hausse des
tarifs réglementés de l'électricité
pourrait en réalité atteindre les 20 à
25 % des buts 2022 c'est en tout cas ce
qu'affirment certains experts du secteur
si la hausse est plus conséquente que ce
qu'avait prévu l'exécutif comme
l'affirment ses spécialistes alors les
dépenses devraient l'être aussi ainsi si
le coût de la limitation de
l'augmentation des tarifs estimé à 4
milliards pourrait coûter jusqu'à 12
milliards d'euros mais selon une source
à matignon pas d'inquiétude car d'autres
outils sont mobilisables en fonction des
prix et s'il était avéré bébut 2022 que
l'objectif d'une hausse de quatre pour
cent ne peut être tenue le gouvernement
pourra toujours intervenir en mobilisant
d'autres outils mais alors pourquoi les
tarifs de l'électricité risque-t-il
d'augmenter beaucoup plus depuis 2011
dans le cadre de la reine l'accès régulé
à l'électricité nucléaire historique edf
cède un quart de son électricité
produite à ses concurrents mais au fil
des ans le marché s'est développé et le
nombre de fournisseurs a augmenté ces
derniers sont donc en gros obligé de se
fournir sur d'autres marchés avec des
prix qui sont beaucoup plus élevés mais
alors l'état pourra-t-il tenir sa
promesse oui à rassurer la ministre de
la transition écologique quoi qu'il
arrive l'état protégera ce n'est jamais
une folie d'accompagner nos citoyens
dans des moments de crise à quelques
mois la présidentielle l'exécutif
souhaite donc tenir son engagement quoi
qu'il arrive au plus tôt quoi qu'il en
coûte
et toujours en france cette arrestation
ce matin à l'aéroport roissy charles de
gaulle de l'un des membres présumés du
commando qui a assassiné le journaliste
saoudien jamal khashoggi en 2018 à
istanbul le suspect un homme de 33 ans a
été interpellé par la police des
frontière alors qu'il tentait de prendre
un vol pour ryad et aurait été placé en
rétention judiciaire dans le cadre d'un
mandat d'arrêt international émis par la
turquie la justice française doit
examiner son éventuelle extradition vers
la turquie à l'époque les investigations
avaient conclu que le journaliste avait
été assassiné par un commando d'une
dizaine de personnes son corps n'a
jamais été retrouvé
et l'arabie saoudite justement et les
émirats arabes unis qui viennent
d'acheter des avions de chasse rafale à
la france une vente controversée ces
derniers jours alors que les ventes
d'armes atteignent des niveaux record
ces d'éditos de katia pique nique
le coc vide a mis à genoux toute la
planète des pans entiers de l'économie
mais la petite entreprise de l'armement
ne connaît pas la crise alors que le
monde se confiner hiberner les marchands
de canons négocier leurs arsenaux
flambant neuf les plus grands groupes
d'armement ont enregistré des ventes
records en 2020 selon une étude de
l'institut international de recherche
sur la paix de stockholm
en effet les 100 plus grands fabricants
d'armes ont totalisé 531 milliards de
dollars soit 470 milliards d'euros alors
que l'économie mondiale chuté de 3,1
pour cent le secteur de l'armement
croise et de 1 3% il faut dire que ce
marché a été soutenu durant la crise
épidémique dans une grande partie du
monde les dépenses militaires ont
augmenté et certains gouvernements ou
même accélérer leurs paiements à
l'industrie de l'armement afin de
limiter l'impact de la crise de lakovic
19 qui figurent dans les dix premiers
marchands d'armes dans le monde six sont
américains il n'y a qu'une entreprise
européenne dans le top 10 un britannique
et trois groupes chinois y figurent les
compagnies chinoises du top 100 ont
vendu pour 66,8 milliards de dollars
d'armes en deux 1020 elle représente 13%
des ventes d'armes total du top 100
outre la croissance de l'empiré du
milieu dans le secteur de l'armement une
autre tendance est à noter les grands
groupes américains acquiert de petites
entreprises prometteuses dans les
technologies spatiales augurant du futur
de la guerre le marché fut donc
florissant pour tous en 2020 pour les
groupes du top 100 à l'exception de la
russie qui a enregistré une perte de 6
25% et de la france qui encaisse -7 7%
par ailleurs en 2020 la france a réalisé
des commandes pour un montant de 4 9
milliards d'euros contre 8,3 milliards
d'euros en 2019 soit une baisse de 41%
selon le dernier rapport parlementaire
sur les exportations d'armes qu'à cela
ne tienne l'hexagone compte bien revenir
dans la course aux étoiles avec une
vente record celle de 80 avions de
combat rafale aux émirats arabes unis 16
milliards d'euros le plus gros contrat
d'armement jamais signé à l'exportation
la plus importante commande jamais
décroché par dassault aviation il s'est
établi dans le cadre confortable d'un
partenariat stratégique entre la france
et les émirats on écoute le porte parole
des armées hervé grange en notre
présence aux émirats c'est aussi une
vigie sur le sol indien et ce
partenariat est un élément clé de notre
stratégie indo pacifique
ce succès à l'exportation nous devons à
la force de nos liens stratégiques avec
les émirats à une équipe de france
soudée et bien sûr un avion d'exception
c'est 80 rafales seront livrés entre
2026 et 2031 une vente qui a suscité les
critiques de certains politiques comme
yannick jadot qui estime que la france
nous fait honte quand l arme des régimes
autoritaires qui méprise les droits
humains amnesty international a aussi
noté une nouvelle preuve que la france
continue d'ignorer ses engagements
internationaux au profit d'un
partenariat stratégique avec un pays
engagé au yémen et gérard larcher le
président du sénat préfère le
pragmatisme la question des droits
humains existent mais si la france veut
être demain souveraine elle doit
continuer à s'équiper d'armes
d'excellence et à les vendre dans le top
100 des priorités il ya bien les droits
humains mais ils ne sont juste pas en
tête du classement nota bene
et on en vient à l'actualité
internationale
principal de la journée le président
russe vladimir poutine et son homologue
américain joe biden se sont donc parlé
pendant deux heures cet après midi
objectif éviter une escalade dont
l'ukraine un échange de politesse en
visio conférence très attendue et
diffusées par la télévision russe on
retrouvera notre correspondante one
claireaux en direct de moscou bonsoir
antoine alors que retenir de cet
entretien en tout cas côté russe
oui stéphanie et bien j'aimerais
beaucoup vous en dire plus mais à
l'heure actuelle le kremlin n'a toujours
pas officiellement réagi à ce sommet
virtuel entre vladimir poutine et joe
biden on suppose que le chef de l'état
russe a défendu sa position concernant
l'ukraine répétant une nouvelle fois que
la russie n'avait nullement l'intention
d'envahir son voisin il a également dû
faire savoir à son homologue américain
que moscou considérait un rapprochement
entre l'ukraine et l'otan comme une
ligne rouge à ne pas franchir mais
encore une fois rien d'officiel donc le
kremlin n'a pas encore publié deux
communiqués concernant cette rencontre
cet échange d'aujourd'hui en
visioconférence entre les présidents
américain et russe merci antoine un
clairon donc en direct de moscou revoir
sur l'ancien petit peu plus du côté de
washington où joe biden donc s'est dit
lui content de s'entretenir avec
vladimir poutine on y retrouve notre
correspondant thomas bonnet bonsoir
thomas un entretien cordial sur sur la
forme mais qui manifestement est loin
quand même d'avoir apaisé toutes les
tensions en croire les dernières
déclarations de joe biden ce soir
oui le ton employé dans le communiqué de
la maison blanche parce qu'il y en a un
est maintenant plus ferme nettement
ferme de la part de joe biden qui dit
avoir averti vladimir poutine de
possibles sanctions en cas d' escalade
des tensions dans la région je vous
propose donc d'écouter le communiqué
assez succinct publié par la maison
blanche quelques minutes seulement après
cet entretien en visioconférence
le président by john a exprimé les
profondes inquiétudes des états unis et
de nos alliés européens à propos de
l'augmentation des troupes russes
entourant l'ukraine et a clairement
averti que les états unis et nos alliés
répondrai avec de fortes mesures
économiques ainsi que d'autres mesures
dans l'éventualité d'une escalade
militaire
le président baden a réitéré son soutien
à l'intégrité territoriale et la
souveraineté de l'ukraine et a appelé à
une désescalade et un retour à la
diplomatie
problèmes de liaison a malheureusement
avec thomas bonnin en direct de
washington et on va aller plus loin avec
nos invités régis le sommier grand
reporter pour rt france ainsi que claude
blanchemaison qui nous ont rejoints
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être
avec nous on l'a vu à un apaisement
comme le disait thomas commencer nous le
dira thomas sur la forme enfin quand
même avec des petites menaces ça se
finit un petit peu toujours comme ça
régis le sommier joe biden qui donc
brandi la menace dès des sanctions
économiques sur moscou c'avait été
annoncée donc confirmée par joe biden
effectivement que
si en cas d'invasion de l'ukraine a re
par l'armée russe et bien les états unis
ray piquerait essentiellement durcissant
les sanctions en s'attaquant
effectivement aux banques aux
possibilités aussi de conversion du
rouble savez dans d'autres monnaies ça
c'est les voiles et les un petit peu là
la palette d'aidés comment des choses
qui vont être qui pourrait être employée
aussi cette éventualité se produisait ce
qui est intéressant quand même
peut noter cette fois ci c'est qu'il ya
quand même eu concertation la part de
joe biden avec ses alliés c'est parce
que nous avait habitué les états unis
récemment avec leur retrait
d'afghanistan et le fameux contrat de
sous-marins subtilisé au français donc
là il
s'avère que les états unis donc joe
biden a promis d'abord 2 va appeler
ensuite emmanuel macron angela merkel et
que mon drive et aidera hier voilà de
mario draghi donc là il ya une prise en
considération dans le cas du chrétien
avec ont le sens puisque emmanuel macron
aussi réagi là dessus une volonté aussi
de deux d'abord donné 2 2 comment de
temporiser de la part des français
notamment et de revenir à des formats
normandie dans le cadre de donc du coup
de rester dans la diplomatie en tout cas
et on sent que ce coup de fil de joe
biden comment avec eux et vladimir
poutine est resté dans ces cadres qui a
pas eu d'escaladé que à mon avis il ne
faut pas attendre d escalade dans les
jours qui viennent même analyse que
manche maison c'est vrai qu'on a vu deux
hommes qui s'étaient quand même un petit
peu invectivé d'un enfant se souvient
quand même que joe biden avait traité de
killer l'admirent poutine la voilà il
était apparemment content de se voir
mais avec quand même c'est ces mots un
petit peu ferme ça peut faire changer
tout même les choses ont même si on ne
connaît pas encore bien le contenu de
cet échange prescient un petit peu comme
à genève le le 16 juin dernier je crois
que les deux chefs d'état veulent parler
clair et parler franc pour essayer
d'arriver à des accords à partir de
positions spontanément très divergentes
en juin ils s'étaient mis d'accord pour
créer deux groupes de travail très
important l'un pour renouer avec les
négociations stratégiques nucléaires
puisque c'est eux qui ont le plus grand
stock d'armes nucléaires et de et de
fusées et l'autre sur les attaques cyber
pour justement en limiter la portée est
aujourd'hui en effet devant les le bruit
que font les tambours de guerre à la
frontière ukrainienne et bien et ils ont
probablement parler clair de la position
de l'un et de l'autre
vladimir poutine il veut deux choses sur
l'ukraine il veut premièrement obtenir
l'autonomie du dombass c'est à dire des
deux provinces de louhansk et de donetsk
de l autonomie pour l'euro profite des
pro russe et puis deuxièmement il veut
il l'a dit la semaine dernière au
kremlin une garantie juridique que
l'otan n'avancera pas en ukraine et
notamment nasrallah n'a n'aura pas
l'installation militaire permanente en
ukraine alors ça c'est deux points
évidemment très très difficile à obtenir
et il est probable que joe biden a a
fait valoir les difficultés qu'il y
avait à obtenir à obtenir les deux
points le premier c'est évidemment dans
un format normandie que ça peut se faire
mais peut-être que pour
cela il faut préciser comme nous le
disait tout à l'heure aussi régis le
sommier que pour le moment l'europe a
quand même été laissés à l'écart de ces
discussions sur les stratégies qu au
mois deux au mois de juin alors que cela
concerne directement parce que les
fusées qui passe au dessus de sa tête
peuvent aussi tomber en europe et
notamment lorsqu'elles sont de portée
intermédiaire là l'europe n'est pas
tenue à l'écart parce que c'est un
problème européen est effectivement
j'imagine que vladimir poutine a demandé
à bayonne d'essayer de faire pression
sur le président ukrainien pour qu'il
assouplisse sa position sur les
consultations avec les pro-russes de dos
du dombass de manière à pouvoir y
organiser les élections puisque c'est le
point qui bloque depuis déjà très
longtemps on l'a mise en oeuvre de minsk
et que monsieur et l'ins qui ne veut
rien entendre sur cette affaire et
considère que d'abord il faut qu'il
récupère le contrôle de la frontière
avec la russie ce que la russie n'est
pas prêt à lui donner peut-être un
compromis un jour sera d'y installer des
troupes de l'ouest et e.on a sans doute
parlé de l'ouest c'est eux on a sans
doute parlé de revoir l'astral
architecture de sécurité de sécurité
européenne puisqu'on en fait c'est de ça
dont il a été question pendant les deux
heures de discussions
registre saunier ce matin eric zemmour
qui a eu un discours qui est un petit
peu trancher avec le reste c'est pour ça
que ça a attiré mon attention qui disait
george bush père n'a pas tenu sa
promesse de ne pas avancer les pions
avec l'otan en direction de la russie
après la chute du mur de berlin on nous
rappelle le candidat eric zemmour
discours évidemment dissonant en europe
puisque l'europe en général évidemment
reprocher la russie de masse et ses
troupes à la frontière avec l'ukraine il
ya une forme aussi on peut le voir comme
ça de légitimité à vouloir aussi ne pas
se laisser faire et à ceux défendus du
côté russe c'est un discours qu'on
l'entend peu c'est vrai que depuis la
fin de compte si vous avez cités là la
chute la chute du mur hélas la fin de
l'urss
l'otan n'a pas cessé de
d'engranger des pays et de l'europe
aussi c'est élargir il ya une nouvelle
réalité
parfois aussi l'existence de l'otan
étaient mises en cause puisque c'est un
c'est un outil qui était utilisée est
justement dans la tactique bloc contre
bloc à l'époque de la guerre froide et
la guerre froide n'étant plus là pas mal
de critiques de l'otan ont dit pourquoi
on continue à avoir cette alliance
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs cette question
est toujours posée puisque on a à chaque
fois qu'il ya une crise ou récemment de
deux mais j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure le
le problème du traitement des états unis
avec leurs alliés la question de
l'europe de la défense est revenue au
devant de la scène et la question de se
dire comment est ce que l'otan est ce
que l'otan est légitime finalement à
régler alors on sait très bien que à
chaque fois qu'on parle de l'europe de
la défense tout à coup les états unis
brandissent dix ans mais non il y en a
pas besoin donc évidemment que c'est un
outil évidemment ce que dit eric zemmour
est pas entièrement faux sur le fait que
les états unis no fake cessé de croître
justement cette on imagine quand ça
s'est passé parce que il faut quand même
on parle de guerre froide ou de nouvelle
guerre froide quand même voir que les
états unis et la russie sont deux pays
qui à cause ce terme qu'on a inventé à
l'époque ne se sont jamais affrontées
directement
tant mieux ça a failli arriver quand la
russie elle à l'époque a soutenu cuba et
est venu justement dans le pré carré des
états unis là aujourd'hui ce que disent
les russes c'est que si on accorde
justement l'adhésion si l'ukraine
obtient son adhésion à l'otan est bien
l'otan sera directement sur la frontière
de la russie et donc c'est c'est
clairement dans une sphère d'influencé
des russes donc là il ya une question
quand même assez assez peu sensibles et
on peut comprendre la position des
russes sur ce sur ce dossier avec
justement ils ne font évidemment la
crainte d'une escalade que de blanche
maison c'est la ligne rouge je suis pas
sûr je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est l'acte
1 de la révision de l'architecturé
de l' architecture de sécurité en europe
nous vivons encore sur les schémas de la
guerre froide avec l'organisation de
sécurité de coopération européenne dont
font partie les états unis et la russie
et tous les autres pays européens 57 ans
tous mais aujourd'hui effectivement le
le système à tout a changé puisque un
certain nombre de pays sont sortis de
l'orbité soviétique sont devenus
indépendants et que certains sont
rentrés d'ailleurs dans l'union
européenne où le loup dans l'otan et
entre la zone couverte par l'otan et la
russie il reste une zone intermédiaire
l'ukraine la géorgie et quelques autres
pays et il faut régler en effet le
statut de ces pays et la sécurité dans
cette zone intermédiaire et je crois que
c'est ça que vladimir poutine propose au
président américain mais c'est
évidemment très difficile ça prendra
beaucoup de temps et ça ne peut pas se
faire sans les européens en tout cas ce
sont les européens qui comptent comme à
l'époque de la csc eux merci en tout cas
tous les deux clubs en maison régis le
sommier de nous avoir apporté votre
analyse après cette rencontre de près de
deux heures entre joe biden et vladimir
poutine cet après-midi
les jo d'hiver dopés karité peut-être au
menu un des discussions virtuelles entre
les deux hommes cet après-midi la chine
en tout cas exprime sa colère après
l'annnonce du boycott américain en ondes
la défense des droits humains elles
accusent washington de violer la
neutralité du sport une position
partagée par la russie accusé de dopage
et suspendu des compétitions
internationales jusqu'en 2022 samir h m
et
un temps envisagé il est désormais
officiel le boycott des jeux de pékin
par la délégation diplomatique
américaine la maison blanche par la voix
de sa porte parole se justifie
l'administration by donne on verra
aucune représentation diplomatique ou
officielle aux jeux olympiques et
paralympiques d'hiver de 2022 à pékin
compte tenu du génocide et des crimes
contre l'humanité perpétrés par la
république populaire de chine au xix
niang et d'autres violations des droits
de l'homme
un signal fort donc envoyés par
washington qui justifie cette décision
en évoquant entre autres le sort des
ouigours et qu'un est accusée par
plusieurs ong d'avoir interne et au
moins un million de personnes issues de
cette minorité musulmane dans des camps
de rééducation
l' empire du milieu par la voix de son
ministre des affaires étrangères est
monté au créneau
le mensonge du siècle fabriqués par les
états unis sur le prétendu génocide au
xinjiang est depuis longtemps démasqué
par les faits
la tentative des états unis d'interférer
avec les jeux olympiques d'hiver de
pékin par préjugé idéologique sur la
base de mensonges et de rumeurs ne fera
que révéler les sinistres intentions de
la partie américaine
les autorités chinoises ont également
menacé les états unis de contre mesures
qualifiant ce boycott de provocation
politique dans les rues de pékin les
habitants expriment un soutien sans
équivoque à l'événement
je pense que l'amérique manque de
respect aux athlètes n'est ce pas les
athlètes se sont entraînés pendant de
nombreuses années et puis les etats-unis
disent très simplement qu'il ne
participe pas ce qui montre que le
gouvernement américain et lâche mais ils
ne pourront jamais boycotté la grandeur
de la chine tout le monde attend avec
impatience ce grand événement le monde
pékin notre pays et notre peuple sont
tous frais tout le monde espère que
cette réunion serait un succès et que la
communauté mondiale pourra se rassembler
le comité international olympique
affirme respecter la décision des états
unis l'instance qui revendique une
neutralité politique a préféré insister
sur la participation des athlètes
américains huit autres pays dont
l'australie envisage de ne pas envoyer
de délégation officielle à pékin la
nouvelle-zélande a franchi le pas ce
mardi motif invoqué le risque sanitaire
mais le pays n'a pas caché ses réserves
sur la question des droits de l'homme en
chine
et dans le reste de l'actualité le
soudan où des milliers de personnes se
sont mobilisées contre l'accord signé
entre le général abdelfettah à la bourre
année le premier ministre à des lames
amdocs issus de la société civile un
rassemblement à khartoum pour appeler
une nouvelle fois au départ des
militaires au pouvoir après le coup
d'état du 25 octobre contre le
gouvernement de transition
ces derniers assurent vouloir conduire
le pays à des élections fixée à juillet
2023 et cette crise politique intervient
sur fond de tensions communautaires au
darfour où 48 personnes ont été tuées
dans des affrontements tribaux la région
aura déjà été le théâtre d'une longue
guerre qui a fait au moins 300 mille
morts et deux millions et demi de
déplacés selon l'onu françois xavier
lambert
des abris de fortune s'accumulent aux
abords des quelques bâtiments dur qui
forment le village de djeddah dans cette
petite localité du darfour occidental
les réfugiés tentent de se protéger
comme ils le peuvent du soleil de plomb
la plupart ont fui les violences qui
déciment des villages entiers en raison
de conflits tribaux mais malgré les
mauvaises conditions de vie s'est
déplacé assure ne pas avoir d'autre
choix
il n'y a pas de maison gh de temps ici
une salle de bains est utilisé par 20 à
30 personnes
ma femme se tient devant la salle de
bain quand je suis dedans et puis je
sors et l antre et ainsi de suite
l'odeur est très désagréable
selon l'onu il y aurait près de 3
millions de déplacés au soudan dont une
majorité au darfour
une région ravagée depuis près de 20 ans
par des conflits sanglants
l'insécurité quasi permanente conduit
ses sous d'année à changer parfois
plusieurs fois de camp pour fuir les
dangers des souffrances auxquelles
s'ajoute un autre fléau celui du viol
parmi ces femmes nombreuses sont celles
qui rapportent en avoir été victime avec
d'autres exactions
nos souffrances ont commencé en 2003 et
se poursuivre jusqu'en 2021 nous avons
été tuées violées et brûlé nous n'avons
pas été en mesure de trouver du
réconfort jusqu'à aujourd'hui
même obtenir de la nourriture ici est
très difficile une famille qu'elle
compte une ou dix personnes reçoit la
même ration cette ration peut suffire à
une famille avec un enfant pendant 20
jours mais ne durera que trois jours
pour une famille de dix enfants l'enfant
la mère et le père cherche de quoi
gagner de l'argent
mais nos filles qui travaillent en
lavant le linge en ville sont violés
alors que la crise politique s'enlise
des millions de soudanais continue de
vivre dans des conditions indignes
gagnés par un sentiment d'abandon le
pays manque toujours cruellement
d'infrastructures et peine à tirer
profit de ces millions d'hectares de
terres arables dans ce contexte les
nations unies se montre pessimiste en
2022 30% des sous d'année auront besoin
d'une aide humanitaire selon l'onu c'est
le taux le plus élevé depuis une
décennie dans le pays et en gambie à
présent la position conteste les
résultats de la présidentielle de
dimanche et la victoire du chef de
l'état sortant adama barro de nouveaux
heurts ont eu lieu la nuit dernière à
banjul la capitale
thibault jeanne à
une intervention policière pour
disperser la foule les résultats de
l'élection présidentielle n'ont pas fait
que des heureux en gambie quelques
heures après la proclamation de la
victoire d'adama barreaux des
manifestants se sont rassemblés ce lundi
soir devant la maison du de l'opposition
ousseynou darbo acérées kunda pour
contester l'issue du scrutin ils étaient
des centaines à rejeter la réélection du
président sortant en réponse la police a
tiré des gaz lacrymogènes la police a
fait tout le chemin depuis 'pipeline'
jusqu'ici pour lancer des gaz
lacrymogènes et vous pouvez voir combien
de personnes tombent ici les gaz
lacrymogènes entre même dans la salle du
chef du parti ce n'est pas juste nous
sommes seulement ici pour écouter nos
chefs plusieurs personnes dont des
enfants ont été pris en charge dans des
ambulances après avoir inhalé des gaz
certains ont été conduits vers des
unités de santé une vive contestation
malgré l'appel au calme lancé par le
principal adversaire d'adama barreaux
cela me dérange beaucoup si par votre
conduite vous troubler la paix et cela
peut conduire à vous savez à quoi ça
peut mener des touristes ils vont avoir
peur ils vont rentrer chez eux et cela
conduira au licenciement de plusieurs
jeunes qui sont employées dans le
secteur touristique et vous savez tout
comme moi que le chômage des jeunes dans
ce pays est l'un de nos plus grands
problèmes nous ne voulons pas aggraver
ce problème
ousainou darboe qui conteste lui aussi
les résultats avec les autres dirigeants
de l'opposition il dénonce un retard
excessif dans l' annonce des chiffres et
n'exclut pas d'engager des poursuites
judiciaires si nécessaire
le candidat battu a obtenu 27 7% des
voix loin derrière le président sortant
réélu avec 53% des suffrages lors d'un
scrutin marqué par un taux record de
participation près de 87% la première
élection présidentielle depuis le départ
en 2016 de l'ancien dictateur yahya
jammeh cinq ans plus tard la stabilité
du pays sorti de son isolement politique
reste encore fragile
cette contestation électorale risque de
venir l'ébranler assez avec nous dans
quelques instants nous parlerons de la
situation sanitaire
fermeture des discothèques incitation ou
télétravail vaccination des enfants le
gouvernement a dévoilé sa stratégie hier
soir pour freiner la cinquième vague
emmanuel mettront un fait et lui de la
vaccination des européennes question
d'appartenance au président qui va
jusqu'à ironiser sur l'efficacité du
vaccin russe août nick v
[Musique]
le long chemin de la réconciliation
nationale depuis deux décennies en côte
d'ivoire au moins le processus est il
sur le point de se concrétiser le
blocage véritable se situe au niveau des
hommes politiques plus de 3000 ivoiriens
en perdront la vie lors de la crise post
électorale de 2010 2011 avec beaucoup
d'attention ça tire de partout c'était
s'était formé à l'as cozes et canton
soit et envoyait des tasses des balles
principal envoyer des cadavres en moins
d'une semaine c'était c'était le chaos
après 2010 il y avait deux camps celui
des vainqueurs et des vaincus est-ce que
la situation s'est quand même amélioré à
ce niveau le chemin que la victime se
plaignent toujours le fait est que sur
le terrain la division existe toujours
le fait est que le climat politique
n'est pas encore véritablement apaisé
[Musique]
la nouvelle calédonie il faut l'ultime
référendum sur l'indépendance est
maintenue au 12 décembre quel poids
représente aujourd'hui un build mokaddem
les indépendantistes dans le paysage
politique en nouvelle calédonie qu il ya
une progression du oui le peuple
originel concernés par la dépendance il
l'indépendance une d'adventices au camp
il représente la france pour la société
calédonienne il n'y a pas eu de n -
roger de la france cet allié quand même
qui n'est pas ça c'est la lia de
consumérisme d'assistanat ou ce que dit
j'ai un économiste une économie assistée
sous perfusion si on fait des
statistiques cruel pour vous retrouver
plus de kanaks dans les prisons pour les
hôpitaux psychiatriques ou marche une
société que dans la réussite au niveau
social
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y à ces dérives lui classiques basés
sur l'ésotérisme et il ya un autre
terrain de jeu pour les gourous qu'on a
découvert notamment avec la crise
sanitaire 1 c'est internet on est moins
ceux des jo de mystique moins religieuse
comme on peut et on pouvait l'avoir
110-80 que sur des phénomènes qui vont
concerner la santé ou l'alimentation et
la crise du coc vide à renforcer cette
nouvelle porte d'entrée dans les dérives
sectaires ou des goûts vous plutôt
parler de vaccination plutôt parler
d'alimentation plutôt parler de guérison
au lieu d'aller directement sur un
terrain qui sera un terrain religieux ou
mystique on retrouve par exemple dans
les dernières manifestations anti vaccin
contre le coc vides certains éléments
qui se rattachent à des mouvements à
tendance sectaire qui historiquement
sont opposés à toute vaccination
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions des procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux et
d'aidé de jean ignoble en fait vous ne
savez pas comment votre fils est mort
vous devez enquêter sur tout et vous
confronter
les faits ni sur la liste des morts nés
sur l'idée bessines sur la liste et
hopitalisé il était nulle part est ce
qu'on peut vivre malgré cette douleur
quand j'ai écrit à la fois je souffrais
parce que ça me rappelait des beaux
souvenirs avec stéphane en même temps
c'était très douloureux et puis
aujourd'hui je me suis aperçu que ça
permettait d'extraire de de moi même
toute cette histoire est donc ça m'a
apporté un peu de recul un peu
d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommet à la lutte contre la cinquième
vague de kobe dans france en forcément
du protocole sanitaire dans les écoles
dès demain le port du masque sera requis
dans les cours de récré le gouvernement
qui étudient aussi la piste de la
vaccination pour tous les enfants de 5 à
11 ans et mais le maquereau lui a fait
de la vaccination des européennes
question d'appartenance semble-t-il le
président français qui va jusqu'à
ironiser sur l'efficacité du vaccin de
spoutnik v les vaccins devenu bataille
géopolitique on en débat dans quelques
instants
[Musique]
fermeture des discothèques incitation au
télétravail vaccination des enfants le
gouvernement a donc dévoilé sa stratégie
hier soir pour freiner la cinquième
vague état des lieux avec sébastien zaba
souvenez vous il y a un an la deuxième
vague précipité la france dans un
nouveau confinement trois vagues
successives plus tard le taux de
contamination repart à la hausse et se
rapproche dangereusement du pic
épidémique de novembre 2020 à période
égale le taux d'incidence dépasse le
nombre de 400 cette année et à l'air de
suivre la même hausse constante qu'à
l'automne 2020 du côté des
hospitalisations et ce malgré une
accélération significative de la
campagne vaccinale et des doses de
rappel on observe une hausse santé
publique france a comptabilisé 1665
hospitalisations pour la journée de ce
mardi un chiffre en augmentation par
rapport à décembre 2020 on note
toutefois une hausse plus lente en
partie expliquée par la vaccination et
la campagne de rappel les personnes
vaccinées ont en effet moins de risques
d'être hospitalisées que les personnes
non vaccinées de façon similaire les
décès augmente mais moins vite qu'à
l'automne 2020 alors que le nombre de
décès avoisiner les 1500 personnes dans
la semaine du 23 novembre 2020 un an
plus tard on compte moins de 300 morts
là aussi le résultat d'une vaccination
qui protégerait contre les formes graves
dus qu'aux vives 19 la stratégie
annoncée ce lundi soir par le
gouvernement se concentrera donc malgré
les polémiques sur la vaccination des
enfants de 5 à 11 ans une part non
négligeable de la population susceptible
de transmettre le virus pour les enfants
du primaire nous allons demander un
effort complémente r jusqu'aux vacances
à compter de jeudi prochain le port du
masque sera également requis dans les
cours de récréation et les sports
collectifs avec contacts seront
restreints à partir de lundi prochain
des conditions de restauration seront
aménagés en lien avec les élus locaux
pour limiter le plus possible les
brassages nous maintiendrons notre
politique de dépistage systématique de
tous les élèves
s'il ya un cas positif dans la classe et
de fermeture de la classe au bout de
trois cas positifs si l'ensemble de ces
données concernent le variant delta
l'impact du variant omicron sur la
population reste à déterminer et seront
front de la vaccination justement
emmanuel macron est revenu hier sur
l'exemple de l'efficacité européenne un
président français qui semble savoir que
les dos sur le vieux continent sont bien
meilleures que celles il reste du monde
écoute et
soyez nationaliste vous hongrois soyez
nationaliste polonais ou français vous
ne seriez pas vaccinés ou imparfaitement
peut-être que vous auriez eu vos amis
russes pour vous donner le vaccin
spoutnik qui n'est toujours pas
homologué par l' oms bon courage voulais
être vacciné avec les meilleurs vaccins
au monde que parce que vous êtes
européen
qu'il fait donc de l'ironie sur ce
vaccin rue spoutnik v alors une question
se pose ce soir les vaccins devenu une
bataille géopolitique il y en at il de
meilleurs que d'autres on attend vos
réactions sur le conte télégramme adhère
t france et place au face à face
et avec nous pour en parler joëlle mélin
députée européenne rn bonsoir vous êtes
en direct avec nous joëlle mélin à vos
côtés sur ce plateau depuis boulogne
thomas porte membres du parlement de
l'union populaire bonsoir thomas porte
merci d'être avec nous donc on viens de
l'entendre à emmanuel macron qui appelle
les européens être nationaliste et
ironise notamment sur le vaccin russe ça
vous évoque quoi une forme de mépris
d'arrogance une maladresse tout
simplement donc je crois que je crois
que c'est emmanuel macron il ya quand
même peu de maladresse et tous les mots
sont bien choisis et une forme de mépris
et d'arrogance mais je crois qu'il ya
regarder la situation sanitaire dans un
pays comme la france où on a donné des
milliards à un groupe comme sanofi qui
n'a pas été capable les vaccins donner
la leçon c'est un peu c'est un peu
ridicule mais je crois que emmanuel
macron plutôt que de décerner des bons
points il ferait mieux de se mobiliser
pour ce que nous demandons depuis des
mois c'est à dire la levée des brevets
ce qu'on a aujourd'hui un variant qui
revient qui viennent d'afrique du sud ou
simplement 25% de la population est
vaccinée aujourd'hui donc l'urgence elle
est à lever les brevets et pas à
distiller des petites phrases parce que
c'est pas à la hauteur des enjeux le
jaune mais là le président français qui
affirme que je cite un finalement nous
avons les les meilleurs vaccins du monde
parce que nous sommes européens il
faisait un petit peu la leçon hongrois
notamment votre réaction justement tant
que députée européenne ça vous a étonné
nos deux emmanuel macron plus rien ne
m'étonne honnêtement on était un petit
peu au bout de deux lunes certaine forme
de vraiment de pardon le terme et de
médiocrité pour deux raisons la première
c'est que tous les vaccins entre
guillemets qui ont été mis sur le marché
européen
sont à quelque chose près des thérapies
géniques surface qui a pu être distribué
largement moderne avec faith verts ne
sont pas des vaccins pour en parler
contrairement smic ou sinopharm que les
mac
arn et thérapie génique arn loi des
messages et géré ont été largement
utilisés on n'a pas encore de recul pour
dire si ça marche mieux ou est bien ce
que l'on peut dire c'est qu'il n'est pas
normal de dire qu'on a les meilleurs
vaccins quand on a refusé refusé de
faire l'expérimentation telle qu'elle
doit être fait au niveau de l'ema ou au
niveau des pays je rappelle une chose
c'est conscient dans le spoutnik 2
sinopharm leur méthodologie de
production n'oblige pas à passer par
l'ema que ensuite il est l'aval de l'om
est ce pourquoi pas en tout état cause
cela n'a pas été fait dans aucun sens ce
n'est pour dire que ça marche ni pour
dire que ça ne marche pas c'est
positivement insupportable c'est est
particulièrement insupportable
on va dire au début de l'année 2000 21
ans quand il n'y avait pas encore assez
de vaccins à tous - pour l'europe en
aura bien entendu pas encore assez pour
le reste du monde et quand on est le
président d'un pays où le ministre de
l'intérieur en mars 2000 va a refusé à
refuser de déclencher la cellule de
crise nécessaire pour démarrer le mot
protocole de protection des français je
crois qu'on évite de donner des leçons
vous êtes aux autres pays et
particulièrement des pays qui ont pris
leurs responsabilités je pense en
particulier aux hongrois à tort ou à
raison c'est la suite qui nous le dira
mais on a pas de notion a donné qu'en
soi même on n'a pas permis de protéger
sa population
alors petit retour en arrière avec la
revue scientifique très reconnu zealand
7 pour la revue médicale
fameuse dont scouting est efficace à 91
6% contre les formes symptomatiques du
duc hobbit 19 thomas porte pourquoi
l'europe n'a pas donné la moindre chance
à ce sérum russe malgré donc ses études
quand même extrêmement sérieuse et est
encourageante pour après effectivement
nous dire que voilà en gros il n'est pas
très efficace e ironisé parce qu'il ya
quand même des procédures ils font
drôlement si je me trompe pas déposer
une autorisation pour avoir après des
tests et des validations et notamment la
validation après de l'om est au final
mais moi je pense qu'il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui de cette question là il faut
être absolument transparent et l'urgence
elle n'est pas amener la guerre sur les
vaccins entre le vaccin russe le vaccin
français qu'on n'a pas et qu'on espère
avoir et les vaccins aux autres pays
sera gelée dit tout à l'heure on a une
situation on a besoin de vacciner
massivement les populations qui ne sont
pas aujourd'hui vacciner et si on veut
pas avoir des variantes qui reviennent
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui des pays
où on n'a pas de vaccination il faut
lever les brevets et on a le président
la république qui nous a dit à quelques
mois je suis contre parce qu'il voulait
protéger certains intérêts financiers il
a rétropédalé en disant je m'engage à ce
qu'on lève les brevets mais aujourd'hui
c'est toujours pas levée on a des pays
notamment l'inde qui est en capacité de
produire ces vaccinations décide de
l'élever et je termine sur un chiffre on
a une enquête qui a révélé qu'ils
avaient quasiment 5 43 2% habitants dans
les pays des revenus et c'est à cette
dose pour cent dans les pays à faible
revenu donc sans vaccination mondiale
aujourd'hui on ne sortira pas de cette
pandémie là puisque vous parlez de pays
on va regarder une carte justement
puisqu'on parlait foot nick v mais mais
pas que évidemment on le voit donc une
centaine de pays utilisent ce sérum
russe de poids lourds à l'inde dont vous
venez de parler thomas porte la chine
l'algérie l'argentine iran le mexique le
pakistan ou encore les philippines les
émirats ou le venezuela joëlle mélin ça
veut dire quoi qu'en gros on croirait
même accro il ya une forme de
vaccination du pauvre on fait le tri la
différence entre certains pays
bas écouter la différence l'union
européenne notamment ciel faire en
envoyant dans le grand lemps kovacs en
envoyant tous les vaccins astrazeneca
que l'europe n'a pas voulu donc pardon
il n'y absolument là encore et malema
trop furent et bien de rester discret et
s'occupait très sérieusement de ce qui
se passe en france et de la réalité de
ces épidémies parce que je crois qu'il
serait plus sage que l'on parle de ces
épidémies y on en est à la cinquième
vague mais à chaque fois ce sont des bus
non pas à part entière ils sont affiliés
les uns aux autres mais on voit bien que
ce qui marchait à 91 92 ou 95% sur le
sur le virus original marche de moins en
moins bien et je vous rappelle
d'ailleurs que la certification puisque
elle a eu lieu ces jours-ci à l'union
européenne s'est faite avec la demande
expresse que les producteurs de vaccins
ou de processus arn messager ou adn
messages et les face à partir de
modélisation des futures épidémies
exactement commencé pour la grille tous
les ans depuis maintenant des dizaines
d'années à partir des souches qui
viennent toujours d'ailleurs d'asie 1
c'est toujours d'est en ouest ont fait
une modélisation à partir des souches
hautement probable pour pouvoir mettre
sur le marché en europe occidentale des
vaccins pour la grippe qui une fois sur
dix marche bien et puis des fois il ya
un échappement parce que la mobilisation
n'est pas adapté et cette année là on
dit qu'il ya eu une mauvaise grippe mais
il est urgent de travailler sur les
modélisations c'est ce que l'europe a
demandé enfin nous avons énormément de
retard alors après comme monsieur porte
parle de lever des relevés on sait déjà
que modern à s'y engage lorsque on aura
déjà dépassé déjà cette fabrication là
et qu'on passera sur des d'autres
vaccins mais il faut se dire aussi c'est
jusqu'à présent ça ne servait à rien
puisque seules les chaînes de production
de très grands laboratoires appuyé
d'ailleurs je tiens à le rappeler sur
énormément de laboratoire remarquable je
pense en particulier en france de
nombreux l'amant qui n'ont pas fermé
leurs portes à proprement parler ils ont
disparu en tant qu'entité ils sont tous
devenus sous traitants et c'est avec ses
sous traitants on a pu sucre 55 sites le
fabriquer ces cinq vaccin européen
donc monsieur macro véritablement n'a
vraiment pas ironisé comme ça c'est pas
le moment et on peut trouver des
solutions soient levées les brevets mais
personnellement je ne suis pas j'ai une
argumentation pour vous dire que ce
n'est pas utile puisque les cris sont
faits au niveau des états donc aux états
de faire des produits des prix adaptés
et à la propriété intellectuelle reste
inchangé voilà c'est vraiment pas le
moment de parler comme parle monsieur
m'apprend surtout s'il veut se montrer
digne d'être à la présidence de du
conseil européen pour les six mois à
venir mais justement thomas porte
clairement emmanuel macron fait de la
politique quand il ironise sur sur
d'autres sérum ainsi on rappelle quand
même un clash chine a promis à l'afrique
des dons de 600 millions de doses de son
vaccin de production conjointe
concrètement pékin fait beaucoup plus
que le dispositif
kovats il faudra qu emmanuel macron
changer les choses quand il prendra la
tête de l'europe j'espère qu'il prend un
peu la tête de l'eau 30 ça veut dire que
jean luc mélenchon serait arrivé au
pouvoir mais vous avez tout à leur dit
il ya une vaccination à deux vitesses
pour les riches et pour les ports
effectivement parce qu'il ya le
dispositif kovacs qui est celui qui
permet normalement de fournir des doses
aux pays les plus pauvres on avait parlé
d'un objectif de deux milliards de doses
en 2021 on est à peine aujourd'hui à 450
millions de doses et on en a le même
temps les trois multinationales qui ont
failli d'heure moderna et bien une terre
qui font quasiment 1000 $ de profits par
seconde alors elles ont été gavés
d'argent public parce qu'on peut parler
de propriété intellectuelle on peut
parler aujourd'hui de la question des
brevets mais ces groupes là ils ont
aujourd'hui trouvé des vaccins parce que
de l'argent public a été investi
massivement et la santé c'est pas un
coup donc c'est pour ça qu'il a eu de
l'argent public et n'a pas trouvé de
bien sûr ça c'est la responsabilité de
la france parce que je veux souligner
c'est grâce et grands groupes ont
bénéficié d'argent public et la santé
n'est pas un coup donc aujourd'hui c'est
un bien commun le vaccin et si on veut
sortir de la situation pandémique dans
laquelle se trouve la planète
aujourd'hui il faudra bien revenir sur
ces logiques libérales et de profits qui
aujourd'hui font de la marchandisation
sur la santé
inégal dans le monde les pays riches
organise une campagne de troisième dose
et seulement 25% de la population des
pays en voie de développement a reçu
pour sa part une première dose
clairement là l'europe doit jouer un
rôle
bien dans la mesure où effectivement
nous avons affaire à un virus mais moi
je dirais plutôt des virus des virus ne
l'on pourrait peut-être arrêter par la
vaccination
tout à fait d'accord pour dire qu'il
faut que des efforts soient faits charge
aux états sa charge à l'union européenne
et à des grandes entités de trouver des
solutions pour que la majorité de la
planète soient protégés sauf que je ne
suis pas tout à fait sûr que ça se passe
comme ça et qu'il ya peut-être d'autres
mesures à prendre que de ne parler que
de vaccination nous avons bien vu que de
la même façon que l'on n'a pas souhaité
évaluer le spoutnik et sa demande a été
déposée en mars 2021 à l'union
européenne auprès de l'ema ya toujours
pas de réponse à ce que je sache l'om
est à fait pareil il faut absolument
faire une expérimentation de tout ce qui
se présente est un peu des alternatives
comme la chloroquine ivermectine ou
houleux où d'autres produits dont on n'a
pas souhaité aller jusqu'au bout des
expérimentations tout ça pour nous
mettre dans l'impasse somme toute d'une
vaccination qui est manifestement très
imparfaite à la fois dans le temps parce
que vacciner une bassin où il ya de la
rougeole ou une autre pathologie ou même
une crypte d'hiver en a en europe
occidentale c'est une chose thaksin est
la planète entière c'en est une autre
enfin c'est à dire il faut quand même
avoir la notion d échelle et des lignes
de production les lignes de production
les sons fonctionner à partir du mois de
mai le peu qu'on avait entre décembre et
avril était très insuffisant ne serait
ce que pour l'europe et à ce propos la
route nick nous a été proposé emmanuel
macron ne l'a pas acceptée peut-être que
certaines personnes n'ont pas bénéficié
de ces soins là en temps utile donnez
moi de vous tromper mais pourquoi mais
pardonnez moi pourquoi selon vous ces
pièces n'ont pas été non n'ont pas été
étudiées jusqu'au bout comme vous et net
je crois qu'il ya des réponses multiples
et certaines peuvent s'entendre au titre
de la recherche nécessaire et du temps
nécessaire pour des développements de
phase 1 2 ou 3 mais je crois aussi quand
même qui a eu beaucoup de rétention
d'information nous vivons dans une
période et on peut ne donner tort à
personne et résidant à personne il est
vrai que rien n'est clair tout est
opaque chez moi même vu les contrats des
vaccins il est anormal que tant de fonds
a été mis sur la table mois de janvier
2020 et qu'à ce jour sorties des vaccins
on n'a pratiquement aucune autre
possibilité
on voit apparaître pour certains stades
de la maladie mais pas aux prétentions
mais pas pour les cas contacts on a
aucune alternative qui soit acceptée
avec les sommes mises sur la table que
ce soit par l'europe mais que ce soit
aussi par la barde américaine qui a
largement cofinancer les vaccins
européens que ce soit aux had en inde
que ce soit en chine les sommes mises
sur la table devrait deux ans et demi
parce que l'épidémie a commencé en
janvier 19 voilà on devrait en être
ailleurs il y a beaucoup d'opacité
véritablement au lieu de faire de
l'ironie monsieur matheron devrait taper
sur l'atome demandé à ce qu'on connaisse
l'origine de ce virus tant pour le
connais pas les virologues vous dise
tendance est pas véritablement d'où il
vient on peut pas être hyper efficace on
avance un peu par à laval ne sommes tout
est maintenant par empirisme il faut
absolument dégâts chez d'autres
possibilités de traitement prévention au
niveau des contacts et bien entendu
quand les cas sont avérés en réanimation
nous sommes d'ailleurs de mieux en mieux
formés et où nous avons devant nous au
moins deux morts thomas porte le mot de
la fin vous êtes d'accord excellent
diagnostic opacité rétention
d'informations mais opacité on l'a vu
puisque les nombreux députés européens
ont dû se battre ne serait ce que pour
avoir accès au contrat
donc aux dents au contrat avec big
pharma alors que c'est quand même
aujourd'hui l'europe y avait de l'argent
sur la table et on était en droit de sa
alimente la défiance un but deux passes
à voir ce cas dans les contrats mais on
voit aujourd'hui en france on parle
d'alternative je crois qu'il faut aussi
revenir raison garder moi je pense que
emmanuel macron devrait rendre les tests
aujourd'hui gratuits on peut pas
accepter que des personnes payent à
chaque fois 40 euros qu'elles ne sont
pas vaccinés pour faire un test on va
approcher les fins d'années on doit
pouvoir permettre aux vins aux autres de
se tester pour diminuer la circulation
du virus qui aujourd'hui reprend avec
une force absolument impressionnante
merci en tout cas thomas porte je
l'admets d'avoir été avec nous en direct
pour ce décryptage et ce face à face
merci à vous deux
ailleurs en europe la vaccination
obligatoire du personnel soignant ont
été contestés dans la rue rebelles j
notamment le gouvernement prévoit de
suspendre les soignants qui refusent de
se faire vacciner dès le 1er janvier
plusieurs milliers de personnes ont
marché à bruxelles pour protester contre
cette mesure vous voyez sur ces images
devant le ministère de la santé certains
manifestants ont frappé à la [ __ ]
d'hôtes ont tenté d'entrer de force
avant d'être repoussés par les policiers
anti émeutes à l'aide de gaz lacrymo et
coûter ces quelques manifestants
s'est prêté cette envie vous avez le coc
vite d'une part avec eux
deux personnes qui sont vraiment la vie
et la mort les sonates un site qui sont
saturés
et pas que les soins intensifs les
services hospitaliers sont saturés et il
a une épice mans professionnels qui se
fait de plus en plus entendre et se voir
aussi avec une version de burnout et des
personnes qui se mettent en maladie et
on peut pas en vouloir à nos collègues
et maximum de gouvernement passe quelque
chose on trouve que tout le monde a le
droit de choisir et que même si on est
vaccinés on doit soutenir les autres et
tout simplement parce que si on nous
enlève les noms vaccinale et nous
vacciner bon sens on va pas s'en sortir
c'est déjà dur comme ça donc et puis
c'est notre corps on en fait ce qu'on
veut et du côté de l'autriche le nouveau
chancelier affirmant que l'euro
confinement décidé il ya trois semaines
va prendre fin lundi comme prévu mais
pas pour les personnes non vaccinées
les gouverneurs se sont mis d'accord
pour mettre fin au confinement ce qui
est décisif c'est de savoir comment
comme je l ai déjà dit mais aussi que le
confinement des personnes non vaccinées
et maintenu leur plaît pts
nous devons accepter que le virus fasse
partie de notre vie mais en même temps
la science nous propose des moyens d'y
faire face afin que nous puissions
continuer à vivre en liberté c'est la
bonne nouvelle
qui coupait
maritime gift la vaccination aide la
vaccination protège et la vaccination
représente le fait que nous pouvons
éviter de nouveaux confinement en nous
vaccinons suffisamment
les riches de plus en plus riches et les
pauvres de plus en plus pauvres à c'est
le constat du rapport publié aujourd'hui
par le laboratoire sur les inégalités
mondiales une tendance désormais ancien
mais qui pointe une nette aggravation en
cause notamment la fonte des patrimoines
détenus par les états censés garantir un
certain partage des richesses c'est si
des choix
premier constat la concentration du
pouvoir économique dans les mains d'une
très petite minorité s'est
considérablement renforcée entre 1995 et
2000 21 les 1% les plus riches de la
planète se sont attribués 38 % de
l'augmentation mondiale de la richesse
les 50 % les plus pauvres n'en ont capté
que 2 % à l'échelle régionale l'europe
est la zone la moins inégalitaires du
monde c'est la seule zone où la classe
moyenne tous une part des revenus plus
élevés que celles des 10% les plus aisés
45% contre 36% pour les plus riches à
l'opposé le moyen-orient et l'afrique du
nord sont les régions les plus
inégalitaires les 10% des plus riches y
capte 58 % des revenus autre constat
marquant les inégalités de patrimoine
sont encore plus importantes le
patrimoine est plus concentré parmi les
très riches les 10% duo possède 60 à 80
% du patrimoine contre 35 à 60 % pour
les revenus la pandémie a accéléré la
tendance en 2020 les milliardaires ont
engrangé un gain de patrimoine de 3600
milliards de dollars l'équivalent des
dépenses annuelles de santé de
l'ensemble des états du monde al'inverse
du patrimoine privé les richesses
détenues par les états se sont effondrés
en france de quarante deux pour cent du
revenu national en 1970 ce taux est
devenu inférieur au pib à -13 % en 2020
après une pétition adressée à emmanuel
macron pour une fiscalité plus juste qui
taxerait davantage les plus grandes
fortunes l' ong oxfam s'apprêtent à
interpeller ce jeudi chacun des
candidats à l'élection présidentielle de
2000 22 avec un manifeste fiscal de 15
mesures
[Musique]
le président palestinien poursuit sa
tournée au maghreb objectif préparer des
discussions du prochain sommet de la
ligue arabe qui se tiendra en mars
prochain à alger après trois ans passés
en algérie où le chef de l'exécutif ait
annoncé une aide d'une équivalence de
100 millions de dollars à son homologue
le chef de l'autorité palestinienne
était aujourd'hui à tunis bassem chab
après une rencontre avec le président
algérien abdel madjid teboul le
président de l'autorité palestinienne
entame aujourd'hui sa visite est
tunisienne en vue du prochain sommet de
la ligue arabe c'est ce qui ressort d'un
bref communiqué de la présidence
tunisienne qui n'a pas précisé la durée
de ce voyage officiel de son côté
l'ambassade de palestine en tunisie a
indiqué que mahmoud abbas sera
accompagné par son ministre des affaires
étrangères et des immigrés son
conseiller aux affaires religieuses et
aux relations islamique son conseiller
diplomatique ainsi que son ambassadeur
en algérie fayez abu aita abbas avait
débuté dimanche une visite en algérie et
rencontré lundi le président de madjid
teboul avec lequel il s'est entretenu
des pratiques de l'occupation
israélienne et des derniers
développements concernant la scène
politique en palestine cette visite
intervient pour parachever la
coordination entre l'état de palestine
et l'algérie afin d'inscrire la cause
palestinienne comme le point central de
l'ordre du jour de la réunion de ligue
arabe le président palestinien a discuté
avec les dirigeants algériens des
développements de la cause palestinienne
des violations israéliennes contre la
mosquée al-aqsa et aussi de la
colonisation israélienne
l'algérie connu pour ses positions
historiques en faveur de la cause
palestinienne ne faiblit pas dans la
solidarité qu'elle exprime en verre à
pays qualifié de frère écoutez nous
réitérons le soutien de l'algérie au
combat du peuple palestinien jusqu'au
recouvrement de ses droits bafoués la
question palestinienne reste pour
l'algérie et son peuple non seulement
une cause sacrée mais également centrale
depuis hier la capitale tunisienne s'est
ornée de drapeaux palestiniens pour
cette visite officielle une visite
durant laquelle le chef palestinien
devrait inaugurer le nouveau bâtiment de
l'ambassade palestinienne à tunis de son
côté le palais de carthage a indiqué
qu'aucune conférence de presse ne sera
donnée à l'issue de sadran contre et
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi rendez vous demain dès 20
heures d'ici là n'oubliez pas de réagir
de commenter de poser vos question de
donner vos réflexions sur le télégramme
verte et france en attendant l'actualité
continue toute la soirée
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter ils
étaient ni sur la liste des morts ni sur
la bbc